the house actually says that unions are
making a conscious decision to put
patients at risk because that's what's
happening
good morning
um no I actually think that's a really
insulting statement to our key NHS and
ambulance workers they've not made a
conscious decision to put lives at risk
they've made a conscious decision to
stand up for what they believe is an NHS
that is crumbling beneath their feet and
as they're watching thousands of their
colleagues leave the service every year
because of poor pay and poor working
conditions and a feeling of being unable
to deliver the safe standards of patient
care that they want to that's why
they're making this conscious decision
and it is insulting to say that they're
doing this to put people at risk and as
you will have heard the health secretary
said that hundreds of millions have been
invested in the NHS to try and solve the
backlog he's saying that that is should
be enough and that striking workers
really needs to get back to work
but we have to understand why there's
such a significant backlog and one of
the crucial reasons for that is the 133
000 Staffing vacancies that they are
across the NHS they were literally not
enough staff working in the NHS to
deliver on those services and without an
investment now in the workforce that we
have got now recruitment initiatives are
pointless we need to do everything we
can to protect our NHS workers that are
working in the system right now and that
that could be anyone from from Porters
and patient transport services to
paramedics to nurses we need to invest
in this Workforce Now
now the GMB as I understand it Rachel
Harrison haven't put forward a pay uh
demand uh why is that
well what we asked for when we entered
into the pay review body process in good
faith earlier this year was a
significant increase in Pay Plus a
commitment and a credible plan to
restore a decade of lost earnings and an
immediate down payment on that so that's
what we were asking for and that is what
we would still like to see but what
we're saying to the Secretary of State
and to this government right now is come
to the table talked to GMB talk to the
other health unions and make us an offer
on pay that we can take back to our
members I mean as you'll have heard the
sexual state is unwilling to talk about
pay so does that mean these strikes are
just going to go on
our members are the ones that will
decide what any future action may look
like but it's in the Secretary of
State's hands to end this dispute now
and by this government refusing to speak
to the unions about pay it is them that
are choosing that this dispute will
continue
just the last thought from you Rachel if
you can how how much longer on the
Mandate from this first vote have your
members got for the for the strike
action when do you have to go back to
them
under the Trade union legislations that
are currently in place
um unions have six months from securing
a ballot result for Action to take
action if the dispute continues longer
than that we have to run another ballot
okay Rachel Harrison from the GMP
appreciate your time this morning thank
you thank you